a recent study found that marijuana
approval and use among teenagers is
actually on a downward trend did you
know that yes I liked it I liked it the
title of the articles they don't like
weed anymore
and then the picture tells you the exact
opposite yeah yeah she's not having a
good time now
no she weren't wearing sunglasses you'd
see how sad she was no it's true
apparently teens don't like weed as much
as they used to and now in homes across
America this trend is leading to scenes
just like this one
dad what are you doing We Need to Talk
that's not mine yeah I know it's mine I
put it there three weeks ago you've even
touched dinner do you not know how to
use a lighter told you I don't like weed
why are you against feeling good trying
what was it an indica I can get you a
sativa or a hybrid oh my god exporting I
don't know why are you so weird I don't
understand you are you a cop
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]